We all know that we should be eating healthier,
but does that mean we have to cut out our
favorite fatty foods?
What’s the answer?
The short version: Size matters.
Hey everyone, this is Matt Lieberman filling
in for DNews.
Researchers at Vanderbilt University have
released a new study that offers a new solution
to the age old problem of diet and portion
control.
Now, dieting seems pretty cut and dry, in
principle.
Don’t eat unhealthy food, eat more vegetables,
exercise regularly, shower, rinse, repeat.
But more often than not, our draconian attempts
to cut out the pleasurable fats, salts, and
sugars that our brains crave cause diets to
crash and burn in their early days, or just
make us miserable.
However, the trick is to not “diet” at
all, but to shift the ratio of portions over
time via something the associate professor
of Management Kelly L. Haws calls vice-virtue
bundles.
She and her colleagues discovered that all
people have something called a “taste-health
balance point” - namely, the proportion
of healthy to unhealthy foods in a single
meal that will leave that person satisfied
with their taste and nutritional choices.
It’s different for everyone, and I’m sure
that more than one of you has already decided
that their balance point looks like a Big
Mac with extra lettuce on it.
But here’s the thing: based on the study,
most people fall into a similar range.
Namely, the perfect vice-virtue bundle has
about one quarter to one half vice foods,
and half to three quarters virtue foods.
The example they provide is a plate of french
fries and apple slices.
For most people, their brains only need a
small portion of fries to satisfy the vice
appetite in their brain, while the apple slices
handle the rest of their hunger in a nutritious
way.
The study goes on to theorize that vice-virtue
bundles could revolutionize the the fast food
industry, which has undergone changes as Americans
seek out healthier food options.
By bundling their existing items that are
pure vice and pure virtue, they could create
new and attractive options at a relatively
low cost.
So what can we take away from this study and
apply to our own lives?
By finding our taste-health balance point,
we can allow ourselves the fatty, greasy,
buttery foods that we love, in a portion that
maximizes our desire for healthier options.
The delicious part?
Finding that balance one meal at a time.
So what do you think about this study?
Do you know what your taste-health balance
point is?
Let us know in the comments below.
I’m Matt Lieberman filling in for DNews.
You can find more of my videos over at Sourcefed.
Please like the video and subscribe to the
channel.
Thanks for watching.